نذهب الان مشاهدينا الى الولايات المتحده
وايجاد صحفي
لن اخوضا في التفاصيل الخاصه بهذه الطائره
لديها القدره على حمل الاسلحه ومره اخرى
كانت
حمله اي اس ار او استطلاع في مياه دوليه
وهذا شيء نفعله منذ فتره طويله اما فيما
يخص
الاساليب الاجراءات التي يتخذها لحمايه
طائراتنا ولا ناخذها في التفاصيل النقطه
الاساسيه هنا
هي ان
احد الطائرات ليست غير شائعه لكن مثل هذه
السلوكيات من الطيار او تطير الروسيين غير
امنه
وكرمه مطالبه
التحاليق الامن
هل هذا التصادم كان حادثا بسببي روسيا وهل
الولايات المتحده تستجيب
تعبير عن التحليق غير الامن لهذا الطيار
هل ستحاله متحده استعاده هذه المسيره
عمليات خاصه بالسعاده فيها
هل هنالك فيديو للحادثه وهل ستتفقون هذا
الفيديو
اين في البحر الاسود حصلت مع مدافور بها
من المرجان الجوي الروسي
وهل قلتم
بان هذه المسيره كانت غير مسلحه انا لم
اقل اذا ما كانت مسلحه ام لا لن اخذ
بطبيعه هذه
المهمه كانت تجري عمليه استطلاعيا
وفيما يخص المعلومات المفصله لنا اعطيكم
معلومات غير انها في مجال جوي دولي في
منطقه البحر الاسود
وبعيده عن
المجال الجوي كان الدولي
نحن نمر في عمليه لف صحن معلومات وسنبقيكم
على اطلاع
هل هي
امثالزم بالقول بانها من نوع
التكنولوجيا حساسه
خل الجيش الامريكي
مياه البحر الاسود حل حصلت عليها روسيا
هل هنالك اي وصول بحريه امريكيه في
المنطقه اجراء عمليه استعاده
مره اخرى لنفوض في تفاصيل
على هذه الطائره غير انها منصه استطلاعيه
بسبب الاضرار كنا في موقف اضطرنا بسببه
في البحر الاسود وحسب معلوماتي في ان
روسيا لم يستعيدها هذه الطائره ولكن فيما
يخص جهودنا لاستعادتها المعلومات
كره الشماليه والصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
كوريا الشماليه اعلنت
انها
تركيب رئيس النوويه
اذا
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاجازه الصحافه
اسقاط المسيره الامريكيه التي تصادم طبعا
مع الطائره الروسيه حيث اعلن بان لا افصاح
عن مهمه هذه المسيره بعدما كان السلطات
الامريكيه اعلنت قبل قليل بانها بمهمه
سلميه الان يقول بان لا افصح ومعلومات عن
مهمتها وعن اذا ما كانت مسلحه ام لا هناك
طبعا كان هناك سؤال عما اذا تم استعاده
هذه المسيره التي اسقطت في البحر الاسود
لا جواب حتى الساعه ولن يعطوا تفاصيل عن
عمليه استعادته وان كان الاسطول الامريكي
هناك سيقوم باستعادتها وايضا عن نشاط هناك
تاكيد على ان مجال الجوي للبحر الاسود هو
مجال دولي وبالتالي يمكن للطائره المسيره
ان تكون هناك ولا خرق للقواعد العسكريه
الموجوده وطبعا اكد بان الطائره تم
يعني تم رشه بالوقود مما ادى طبعا الى
اسقطه